you're here Justin because you were mad
he knows a good deal I do and black
friday is coming up which means this is
the time when we celebrate having taken
the country by force and then getting
really good deals on some cool
electronics the problem with black
friday is that it is no longer black
friday it's more like two weeks of
really good deals and it's really really
hard to keep track of what it was an
actual good deals it was black friday
and then cyber monday sort of spun that
off of bed now everyone just does
whatever time for monday came out we
have all these retailers who are online
but now everybody's online it's not like
there's a physical retail store like
there are some things you can only get
in fiscal retail but everyone else is
like it makes more sense to do this
online everything's online so first
things first obviously it's a massive
part of holiday purchasing and I used to
work in retail and like late November
was when people started looking at
buying consoles and why would I tell
everybody to wait like right now is when
you need to have put off getting your
comms yes for sure if you had not bought
it back in the summer like just wait for
now because now you're not only getting
the best deals but the best bundles and
and that's where I think Xbox is really
doing well so last month on the NPD s in
the US Xbox actually outsold the ps4 on
the power of so many bundles and they
have a few more options available now
but you can get a $300 xbox one or a
$300 ps4 through almost every storm
black friday because everybody is
competing with one another to have that
same price so it's a deal you can get
basically anywhere and this is if you've
been putting off getting a ps4 xbox one
this is the time to do it you not only
get a 300 but you can get a really good
game with it so three hundred dollars
for the xbox one obviously means no
connect those are is there a game goes
well why would you want to connect like
oh no I didn't get connect with this
trade it back in and buy by the halo
game and no and it's nice to have the
voice controls but yeah it's not there
and so do they come like what bundles
are in terms of like games you know what
games again I thought it was like a tomb
raider one around so the big one for
PlayStation is of course uncharted I
think that might be the only one with up
with Xbox there's almost every game that
you can get with that there's a bundle
for Tomb Raider the bundle for xbox
there's a bundle for rocks there's a
bundle for tumor what did I say Tom
generator yeah and gears have worked
that is basically xbox i think this
Assassin's Creed one's flying around
maybe as well pump props I think the
Assassin's Creed when you can also get
unity for for free great they need to
give her that yeah everyone needs a new
coaster and what about our good friend
that we you if you've already purchased
the ps4 you got a sick pc and you've got
an xbox one as well and what is there
for the the fourth console for your
living room with it this is the console
that I think everyone else should still
own like Nintendo is a great job at
making the console the you own in
addition to your primary gaming console
and they do have a really good black
friday deal going on it's it seems
similar in price because it's two
hundred eighty dollars you can get the
other systems for 300 but you get two of
the best games Oh what games they are
super smash brothers and splatoon okay
both relatively new as well yes
relatively new two of the best games on
the system the only one that it's
missing that is an absolute must buy a
Super Mario maker there aren't a lot of
good black friday deals on that one but
I think target is having a buy it for
sixty dollars get a fifteen dollar gift
card so ostensibly fifteen dollars and
if you have the gamers club which is
actually really good deal i usually
don't get into those with it's like
gamers club is gives you a good discount
on those games i passed by that is the
best bike okay interesting last year I
bought myself a Wii U is like my sort of
gift to me and I had a bas Rutten
especially because there were so many
really great games that were discounted
by the time that I was picking it up and
on the second hand stuff as well and on
the Nintendo side there's also the 3ds
it for some reason you've been putting
off for the longest time getting yeah
the only handheld console remaining
there's going to be some decent black
friday deals I think you can get that
for about a hundred eighty dollars no
bundles but the new 3dsxl or you know if
you were thinking about upgrading to the
new that's such a dumb name new 3dsxl
one with the extra buttons on it that's
a good time to do that as well I'd give
any alien to what Amazon are doing in
terms of their stuff cuz they off they
often do a lot of like competing they
see the ones that are right there in
retail or online and other digital
stores they try and reach some sort of
parity there so there's gonna be all of
those same deals you're going to be able
to find on amazon well the thing that's
gonna be interesting for amazon is they
always kind of wait till the last minute
to show what their lightning deals are
going to be in with the prices and what
games specifically those are going to be
those go so fast it's really hard for
even us to keep up with it because
they're just constantly flowing through
them and there's so many but that's
you're basically going to have to wait
till that weekend and friday and then
like they just do it for such a long
time Amazon's a good place to keep an
eye on I think that for more individual
games that you want to pick up and
there's some really great game deals
until don't like games that came out
this year until dawn for twenty bucks
it's just twenty bucks twenty bucks at I
want to say best buy I'm as maybe sit
down to 30 since this morning so that's
probably reach amazon always reacts to
that they would drop their prices as
well bloodborne is another one you can
pick up for twenty bucks wow it's like
gaming here contender give me your
contender for twenty bucks you can and
some DLC to add to that so you can pay a
little bit more money as well so we
don't talk about a lot of stuff on video
for the obvious reason that people want
to click links and find out what's new
so for people who want to click links
and find out what's new Justin where's
the best place on gamespot to see us so
if you go to the way that we find
everything also on gamespot because it's
hard to find things in our search bar
just go to go to Google as I've been
gamespot best black friday deals we have
a constantly updated list of those and
if you guys have any deals that you want
to share with as well you can drop those
into the comments we are looking for
good deals to add it's awesome what are
you gonna pick up yourself nothing are
you on all the consoles I iona xbox one
ps4 and wii u and 3ds and i've played
almost all of the big games because i've
had to keep up with them well yeah i'm
gonna be spending most of my
thanksgiving break trying to catch up on
the games that i just haven't had a
chance to well I gave me to your
discussions are starting next week so
here just guesses are technically
starting now oh yeah that's a fair point
I'm gonna pick up one till dawn because
I feel like that's one of those sleeper
hits so I sort of have them spend enough
time with I did some of the the beta
stuff or the preview stuff before game
and twenty dollars is a great price
great price what a great game steam is
the other one so it we don't usually get
as many good pc deals well of course
newegg is one of my favorite stores to
go to for pc parts and architecture for
pc games there's not as many good deals
steam is getting rid of their old model
where they would have a you know every
day they have a rotating sequence of
deals you have daily deals and it was
kind of silly to keep track of him
because there was only one deal that was
good every day and you would just have
to wait for that deal and they're
completely eschewing that what they're
doing now is when they do their their
deal when they're going to do there
halle dealer autumn deal it's going to
be for the entire week these are the
prices okay this is our lowest price you
don't have to wait for a deal to come up
so
or if you want to get up a pc game as
soon as steam releases all of their
deals that's a good idea clockwork tales
of ink at Glasson ink for the yet right
there 250 pick it up while it's hot yeah
let's see the trailer those hot bangers
and artifacts didn't see what the rest
of that was Frank man i love steam it's
the odd [ __ ] bird you call them
bangers isn't that like a sausage hot
bangers yeah sure that's a regional
thing the hot sausages games could be
hot bangers to look at it see these
graphics like fallout 4 it's dope look
at that all those games more highly
positive 316 reviews there came out two
years ago but it still got those hot
next-gen graphics look at that girl
she's so happy also pc exclusive pc
exclusive because who else wanted
clockwork tales the glass gov glass and
egg Malik's all right there you go peace
team it's got it's a whole other thing
going on while we're all talking about
game of the years they've still got all
this stuff crazy madness Justin hey both
thank you so much for going on thank you
telling me how to save some money let me
know folks in the comment box below what
do you think of the deals is really
console you haven't picked up yet we're
kind of deep into this console
generation there so surely you've
already got your primary choice may be
looking at picking up a secondary one
what is it let us know in the comments
below